humillado incomunicado maltratado y
secuestrado así describió Pedro Castillo
sus primeros días en prisión en una
carta escrita con su puño y letra su
primera declaración pública desde que
fuera destituido por el congreso
arrestado por intentar disolver la
legislatura para evitar un juicio en su
contra y denunciado por la fiscalía en
El Congreso por la supuesta comisión de
los delitos de rebelión y conspiración
Castillo arremetió contra sus sucesora
Dina boluarte les hablo para reiterar
que soy incondicionalmente fiel al
mandato popular y constitucional que
ostenta como presidente y no renunciaré
ni abandonaré mis altas y sagradas
funciones lo dicho recientemente por una
Usurpadora no es más que los mismos
mocos y babas de la derecha golpista por
lo que el pueblo no debe caer en su
juego sucio de nuevas elecciones
la agitación en Perú crece con el pasar
de los días con un foco de protestas en
el sur del país donde ya se cuentan
varios muertos los manifestantes
condenan el proceso contra el ex
mandatario y exigen la salida de
boluarte este lunes la presidenta radicó
un proyecto de ley para convocar a
elecciones anticipadas Para abril de
2024 dos años antes de que se cumpla el
periodo de castillo y anunció medidas
para frenar La ola de violencia anuncio
la declaratoria del estado de emergencia
en las zonas de alta conflictividad
social comunico que he dado las
instrucciones para que se recupere
pacíficamente el control del orden
interno sin afectar los derechos
fundamentales de la ciudadanía la
izquierda latinoamericana unió sus voces
para exigir respeto por la investidura
de Castillo los gobiernos de Colombia
México Argentina y Bolivia lo consideran
víctima de un hostigamiento
antidemocrático